last month the global population hit 8
billion people
now like me that is the number I can say
that cannot really comprehend it's big
basically
and the number of people on the planet
are projected to keep growing to 9.7
billion by 2050 and 10.4 billion by the
end of the century
but the rate of population growth is
declining
according to the un's latest reports in
2021 the average fertility of the
world's population stood at 2.3 baths
per women over a lifetime having fallen
from about five births per woman in
1950.
Global fertility is projected to decline
further to 2.1 baths per Woman by 2050.
put that into some perspective a birth
rate of 2.1 bars per woman sustains the
current population size and you can see
here nicely how the fertility rates
impacts population sizes over just three
generations
but that's on the population scale and
two-thirds of the global population live
in a country or area where fertility is
below 2.1 bars per woman now there are
obviously many potential explanations
for these changes but the one I will
further discuss today is about fertility
and whether we really are in a fertility
crisis and what we can do about it
so firstly what do I mean by fertility
here
well we're navigating the literature you
may come across two definitions the case
I have used so far is the more
demographic sense or statistical way of
describing the number of children born
the fertility rates or there is the
biological definition which I'll
probably refer more to throughout the
rest of this video that is of fecundity
by the one can actually reproduce
so is there evidence for a decline in
fertility
well a landspot paper came out in 2017
where their key finding was a
significant decline in sperm counts
measured by spam concentration and total
spam count between 1973 and 2011 driven
by a 50 to 60 decline among men
unselected by fertility from North
America Europe Australia and New Zealand
this paper was co-authored by Dr Sharna
Swan whose book countdown I read a year
ago and one I would highly recommend
though I did also slightly terrify me
and now we have the latest updates for
the studies published between 2014 to
the end of 2019. to see whether the
trends continued post-2011 and the
authors were also interested to see if
the trend spread to South America Africa
and Asia
so again in this matter analysis study
they looked at spem concentration and
total spam count from published studies
that fitted their criteria they then
combine the data with their previous
paper
not only did they see the trends
continue but they also found by looking
at time intervals that there was a
marked increase in the percent Decline
and spam concentration
and they found strong evidence for the
first time of a decline in sperm counts
among men from South Central America
Asia and Africa there are of course some
caveats to be aware of in studies like
this one that it is just a meta-analysis
and that they focused on spam count not
sperm motility or morphology which have
also been associated with fertility but
that said sperm count does have
implications as it has been closely
linked with male fecundity and reduced
sperm count has been associated with
testicular cancer
and increased all-cause mentality and
morbidity but the spam is just one half
of the equation but unfortunately while
there are multiple reports now when
Trends are male reproductive Health
there are not any for female
reproduction
it's not that I'm just trying to avoid
it but either way it raises the question
of why why is there this decline
our human populations living in
industrialized regions at risk of a
catastrophic decline
well that is the opening of a recent
review article environmental factors in
declining human fertility an interesting
read that seeks to investigate the
reasons that may be behind this decline
in sperm count is this decline driven by
genetics or environmental factors
well according to this review no single
genetic Factor has been shown to affect
fertility on a population scale
and two immediate explanations Hawaii
are one the global rate of the client
seems to be fast to be driven largely by
genetics and two if there was a genetic
variant that made someone less fatal
then that person would be less likely to
pass on that trait to the Next
Generation the theory of natural
selection
although that said one could argue that
with multiple assisted reproductive
Technologies now available
you could bypass this natural negative
selection pressure enabling the
accumulation of genetic variants that do
affect fertility moreover with cheaper
and more in-depth DNA sequencing tools
more studies are now being conducted
into reproductive aging to find genetic
variants that are linked with the basic
biology of gametogenesis and
reproductive longevity
interestingly many of these genome-wide
Association Studies have identified DNA
damage repair to be involved
so the genetics is still unclear but
what about epigenetics how the genetic
information is read well epigenetic
marks are Dynamic and can be affected by
lifestyle and environmental exposures
and evidence is accumulating in animal
models that epigenetic patterns can also
be inherited across Generations this
could be through DNA methylation marks
or the presence of small rnas that are
in the sperm or egg
it is a much harder to test this in
humans though
although one human study found the micro
RNA an RNA that influences gene
expression as an auspicious Omen of
in-future fertilization
effectively here they showed that higher
expression of the micro RNA HSA microrna
191 was associated with higher
fertilization rates in IVF
though while this is interesting
research it still doesn't actually
address the question of the current
cause of Decline and spam counts Esters
microenabing depleted over time what
would be the cause of it or what are the
other courses is it Environmental
now doctors want to expose this
extensively in her book she discusses
weights being substantially over
underway it's linked with negative
effects on sperm quality and increased
risk of miscarriage for females smoking
amount of exercise and stress and you
have a topic that both took this one and
the truth you mention are modern
chemicals and industrialization
so things like phthalates BPA and
pesticides which are found in everyday
items but there are no causal studies
only correlations
and I did some research into finding
some evidence for this and one small
study I came across found no link
between BPA levels and body fluids and
couples undergoing IVF but other Studies
have so I'll put some links to the
papers in the description
and going back to what we were saying
about epigenetics it could be that these
environmental exposures or lifestyle
choices of parents and grandparents
could influence the fertility of those
of reproductive age today the fact is
it's hard to prove any of this
but what can we do about it
well there are obviously options
available today such as IVF and other
assisted reproductive Technologies as
well as egg and tissue freezing but
these things aren't necessarily cheap
and they can be invasive and have
Associated risks moreover they treat the
problem they don't actually fix the
cause of the issue
unfortunately but evidently there is
just a massive Gap in our understanding
of what happens during the early stages
of pregnancy for developing fetuses and
how this all impacts reproductive
potential and health
and why does decline is occurring and
what can be done to rejuvenate it
and I think the best phrase to summarize
all this comes from this review article
the difficulty in distinguishing between
biological or behavioral factors
including educational attainments that
affects human fertility has had
researchers to conclude that the
question on the causality underline the
decline in human fertility cannot be
answered but I do like to Amber some
good news and while there is some good
news that is research is being conducted
as we become aware of this problem
but it's not just a scientist problem it
also involves governments and health
authorities
but some of the basically biological
research being conducted I spoke about
earlier this year called in featuring
gametogenesis that is the generation of
spam and egg in a dish instead of
deriving them directly from the body so
you can take an induced periprotein stem
cell and convert it into a precursory
form of an egg and sperm and then use
different culture methods to mature them
this has been done to create fertile or
Springer mice although at the moment
with extremely low efficiency if you'd
like to learn more about this technique
then you should watch this video here
but with that I hope you've learned
something in this video thank you to my
patreon supporters and thank you for
listening